và thông tin từ lực lượng trức năng tại các cửa hợp tình lạng sơn, tương ngày 1 diễn này.
Tại một số khu vực cửa khẩu có mươi giống và gió mạnh gió anh vượn của báo xú bà,
như không anh vượn đến hoạt động sất nhập khẩu.
Bây giờ thông quan hàng hóa vẫn diễn ra o định với khoảng 1 yên sau trăm xói đến một yên 7.7.7.
Tương ngày 1 diễn ngày 25.7, tổng số phương tiện vẫn chuyển hàng hoa sất khẩu nhập khẩu đu thông quan là hơn 5.7.
Trong đó, trên một yên 1 trong phương tiện trở hàng sất khẩu và trên bàn yên 1 trong phương tiện trở hàng nhập khẩu.
Hòa đồng sất nhập khẩu chủ yếu dễ ra tại cửa khẩu quốc tế hữu nghị,
cửa khẩu tinh thành và cửa khẩu chính trì mà.
Các bạn thằng thông quan chủ yếu là nông sản, trái cây tươi của phản bóc, linh kiện định tự,
hoa chất, hàng xa dụng và hàng tiêu dụng.
Để hòa đồng thông quan hàng hóa ủng định trong điều kiện thơ tiếp không thể lợi,
lực lượng chức năng khu vực cửa khẩu đã phương công các cá kíp chực.
Bảo đam quân số điều tiếp phương tiện tại các vị trí quan trọng trong khu vực sất nhập khẩu.
Thường xin tình tra cơ động để kì thời xử li các vấn đề phát sinh liên quan đến gặp ủng khi mối lớn.